Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 13 on string streams and assertions.
So, we have been working with streams that print to a source and read from a sink.
That source has been your keyboard or a file, and the sink has been the monitor or a file or a screen.
But instead of writing output to the screen or a file, or reading input from a keyboard or a file,
a string stream reads and writes data to and from string objects in memory.
Now to use string streams we have to include a new header. They are not included in Iostream or Fstream.
This header is called Sstream. So for output files we create a new output string stream which is called an OStringStream.
Now when you create that output string stream, nothing has been written to it yet. There is no data, so it is empty.
You can write any kind of data to it using the regular interface of the stream classes.
You can use put, you can use the extraction operator, you can print of course strings like this, or you can print integers.
All of them will be converted to output in this string stream.
Now once you have the data, what you want to do is you want to make a copy of the string that the string stream contains.
And you do that by calling the member function str.
So when you are finished writing, you get a string object, you extract it from the string by calling out.str.
Now string streams are really useful when you need to mix numeric and text formatting.
So in Java you do something like this, str.ance = the answer is colon + 42.
And Java would automatically convert this 42 to a string and concatenate it with this string.
In C++ what you do is you take an OStringStream, an output string stream, and you would print the answer is and then 42.
And then you would say string out = outString.
Now you can reuse the same string stream object over and over again, in other words print a line, extract the string, print a line and extract the string.
But when you do that you need to clear out the old string object.
And you do that by calling str. function, but this time instead of passing no arguments, you pass an empty string.
And that will give you a fresh stream buffer. So this is like set the string I'm carrying to nothing, this is like get the string that I'm carrying around to nothing.
So we are going to do an exercise here.
And we are going to write a function that takes a double monetary value and returns a dollar formatted C++ string.
And you would use the function like this. If you have an amount, you would simply write $2 amount when you do cout and that would convert it to this dollar formatted string.
So if the amount was 1234, it should produce $1,234.00
So let's go ahead and do that. Make sure you have opened up your VSCode. And this is in 13A, so let's open dollars there.
Let's open a shell on it, open an integrated terminal.
And let's complete the $2 function here.
So let's put our ID up here.
Ok, so I'm going to put this down a little bit and put that over here so we can see the code a little bit more.
Ok, so the function is going to return a string. It's named as $2.
It is going to take a double amount.
And we want to turn that into a string. Now to convert a double to a string, we just do this.
$string $out $out $fixed $setPrecision $to $out $amount
And return $out.$string
So we created a string stream. We set the formatting on the string stream.
We printed our amount to the string stream. And then we extracted the string from that and returned the string stream.
So let's go ahead and try that. Let's do a test. It's not going to be correct yet because we haven't put in the commas or the dollars.
But you notice it is in fact turning our thing into a number with two decimal places here at the end.
So now all we need to do is we need to insert the comma and the dollar sign.
We can do that using string formatting.
So basically what I'm going to do is I'm going to say $str = $out$str
Now what I want to do, so let's look at what we have for our output string.
So I have something like this.
Let's see if that in fact copied control C.
It might not have.
Maybe I can copy it like
No, it doesn't look like I can copy it.
Oh, I can copy it. I did copy it.
So what I want to do is I want to go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 and put in a comma.
Hi folks, I'm back. I kind of got interrupted there for some meetings and an office hour and so forth.
OK, so let's return to this problem of the $2 function.
What we're going to do here is rather than just returning $out$str
We're going to save the output as a result variable, as a string.
And then we're going to return the dollar sign, the space and result at the end.
And now all I need to do is I need to look inside here and find out where to put commas.
I need to add one comma here.
And so obviously it needs to be greater than 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 characters before I add a comma.
Otherwise, it's fine just the way it is.
So if result size is greater than 6, what we're going to need to do is split it up and bring in commas.
So the place where I'm going to put the first comma is at position 6.
If it's only 6 long, it doesn't need a comma.
So I'm going to save that in an int variable.
I'm going to call this "pos"
And I'm going to get the string size, the result size, minus 6.
And technically, we should do a static cast on this.
But it actually works without it.
The reason we need a static cast is because this is an int.
Because if I'm going backwards here, I want to make sure I can go less than 0 when I'm done.
And so we're going to say result equals result, substring 0, up until the position where the comma is supposed to go.
We'll add a comma to it, and then we'll get the rest of the result.
So that's going to let me get, these three is from 0 to the position.
So that position would be there.
And the second part is from the position to the end, and we added a comma to it.
Now we might need to add more commas.
We can go ahead and try this right here.
Do make test.
And we'll see the first three work, where we only have one, but here I need another comma.
And I might need more here.
Here I have several commas.
And so what I'm going to do is I'm going to say pos minus equals 3, move back three characters.
And while pos is greater than 0, I'm going to say result equals result, substring 0, pos, plus comma, plus result, substring, pos.
Finally, to make that loop go around, I'll need to say pos minus equals 3 if I need another one.
OK, let's see if that does it.
So let's do control L.
Do make test.
And it looks like we have all of ours.
So here I have one, two, three, four commas in this one.
Notice how this also, when we converted it to a string, it converted that .99, rounded up to an 8 for the number there.
So it did that correctly.
OK, so now let's look at input strings.
So in Java you can parse a string by using a scanner.
So I can create a scanner, in equals new scanner, and instead of passing in system in, I can pass the string that I want to parse.
And so then I could simply use in next, which would give me March, and in next int, which would give me the 17 here.
And then I could say int year equals in next year.
Notice that it's kind of hard here, however, to parse it if it's going to contain a comma or something like that.
In C++ you use an input string stream to do something similar.
So here's an iStringStream in, instead of a scanner in.
This is January 1st, 2018.
Notice here I do have a comma in this one.
Then I can get a month.
I can read in the month like this.
I can get an int for the day and the year, and notice month was a string.
An int for the day, the year, and a character for the comma that I want to read.
And then I can just read in the day, the comma, to extract this comma after that and the year.
And this input will skip all of this extra white space.
So really, really very flexible.
So we're going to put that to work.
And we're going to complete a function which takes a string that contains multiple parts.
So we're going to parse the arguments.
And then we're going to print only the input lines following between those lines.
And so this list function will take a string that looks like this.
This says open Alice.text and prints the lines 40 to 50 in Alice.text.
We'll assume that the lines start at 1 and that we'll include both 40 and 50.
Now this time, if the function doesn't work, we're going to return, if it does work, we're going to return true.
Otherwise, we're going to return false.
So let's minimize that. Let's close dollars.
Let's come on over here and open up B.
And open up list.cpp.
So put your ID here.
OK, in the instructions it gives you a little bit more information.
So we're going to attempt a file name that passes the first word.
Cannot open file name or return false.
If the starting number is larger than the ending number, the starting number and ending number are the same.
We're going to print that one line.
We'll print invalid starter end position along with the argument and return false.
If the file is opened and the starting number is not larger than the ending number,
then the function reads the lines specified in the file and prints those lines.
Assume that the line numbers start at 1, not 0.
And print the line numbers in a field 4 wide, followed by a period and a space and the line.
If successful, it should return true.
So we're going to assume it's successful, so I'll add that line.
Return true.
OK, now let's parse args.
So I'm going to create an input string stream, iStringStream.
I'll call it StirIn.
And I'm going to initialize it by passing in the arguments.
Now I'm going to extract from that string stream the file name.
So, string, fName, and StirIn, fName.
Now I want to extract the starting and ending positions.
So, if starting, ending, StirIn, starting, and ending.
OK, so this is how we read from a string stream.
Now let's put this to work and do our two possible errors.
So, we'll do an ifStream, in, and I'll use fName.
If in fail, couldn't open it, we'll see error, cannot open, fName.
And we'll return false.
Another possibility. Starting is greater than ending.
If starting greater than ending.
See error.
Let's just go ahead and copy from the handout.
Args.
And we'll return false as well.
So here we extracted or parsed the data.
Here we're double checking or validating that data to make sure it's OK.
We have the right file name, we can open it.
Now, we're going to go ahead and print the lines.
So I need a int lineName equals one.
I need a string line.
I need a while getLine, in, line.
Let's start the line number zero.
And then immediately say lineNode++.
Now, we're only going to print it if it's in front of, after the starting.
So if lineNode is greater or equal to starting.
See out.
We want a field for wide.
Let's look at our instructions again.
For wide.
And we're going to print the line number in that field.
That's followed by a period and a space.
That's followed by line.
OK, so let's try it.
OK, let's actually close that terminal.
And open up a terminal over here.
Now, we have a problem already.
So we're going to see that when we test the code.
OK, so our checking, invalid start position and position work.
Our checking for the cannot open no file.
But here, we're looking for Moby Dick from 101 to 103.
Expected three lines.
But we found 22,000 lines.
Yeah, 22,000 lines.
And so the problem is that we didn't stop.
We didn't stop when we hit our end.
So let's say.
And.
Line no is less than.
OK, and so that will stop us when we get to the ending number.
Now we have to read all the ones up to the starting number. We don't have to read any of the ones after that.
Alright, let's try it.
Let's do make test.
OK, so here we're running the correct number of lines.
Now you might wonder, you might wonder.
Why I didn't say this if we're going to include the line number.
Because notice we're incrementing the line number before we decide if we're going to print it.
And so if I said less than or equal to ending.
When it was on ending, we'd go and we'd print the next line number after.
So be really careful when you're doing this to make sure that you have this part set up correctly.
OK, so that's it for our string streams and input string stream and an output string stream.
So let's go ahead now and talk about one other topic.
This is assumptions and preconditions.
Now often a function makes assumptions about its inputs.
These are called the functions preconditions.
And for instance, if I say cout the square root of n.
What is assumed about n?
We assume that it's positive number.
If it's not a positive number, the output is not correct.
In the standard library, there's a function called s2i or string to int.
That will convert a string to an integer.
What would we assume about s when we're calling s2i s?
We'd assume that s contains something like 125 and not the word one.
Now at a minimum, when you're writing a function, you need to think about and document your assumptions.
And we do that with a statement called a pre statement.
This is part of the doxygen tags.
So for the square root, the precondition would be that n is greater or equal to zero.
Now, a post condition is what we assume will be true when the functions completed.
Now that may be include things like external side effects.
A global variable will be set.
If you do see output 65, a is set to the standard output.
Right, that's a side effect. That's the post condition.
You should include what the functions assumed to return as well.
So all of these are the post conditions.
And you should document those as well using doxygen tags.
And so at post says the status is true.
If the number is read correctly, we might have more to say about that.
If the function throws an exception, we'd use an at exception tag.
Again, that's part of the post condition.
This is what will happen.
So if the function works correctly, the status is true.
If the function does not work correctly, it throws an exception when the number is out of range.
So again, when you're writing your functions, you want to document those.
You want to allow the people who see the function to know what will happen when an error occurs.
So when we have a precondition violation, when we have inappropriate input given to our function,
we can do five things.
Three of them are appropriate in certain circumstances.
Two of them are commonly done, but are not really very appropriate.
The first is you can make the input fail safely.
So this is sometimes called defensive programming.
Specifically, what you're defending against is the program crashing.
You don't want the program to crash.
So for instance, we could have S2I1 simply return the value zero.
What's the problem with that?
That makes it very hard to find errors in your code.
In other words, you won't find the place where you in fact passed the wrong argument to S2I1.
You'll just get back a zero in that case, which is not really the right answer.
So number one is really not a good idea.
We really don't want that to happen.
Number two, if your function gets an invalid input,
or you notice some other kind of precondition violation,
you can terminate the program with an error message.
Think about would you like that to happen in your web browser.
You type in a URL and Chrome or Firefox crash.
You wouldn't like that.
You try to save a document in Word and the disk is full and it just terminates the program.
Again, you wouldn't like that.
So there are certain situations where that's not appropriate.
Three, you can return an error code, which the user can check.
Or what we've seen with our streams, you can set an error state like see and fail.
When an error occurs, they set an error state.
It's up to us to check that.
Is there a problem with that?
Yeah, actually.
Programmers may or sometimes will just ignore those error states.
So it doesn't force the programmer to handle potential problems.
The way you can force programmers to handle potential problems,
which we'll cover in the next lecture, is you can throw an exception, which can be caught.
Finally, you can do what most programmers do.
That's number five.
You just don't do anything.
You just hope for the best.
Or you say, that's a feature.
It's not a bug.
So all of those are possibilities.
So today in this lecture, I want to talk about one of these situations,
terminating the program with an error message.
When is that the correct thing to do?
Some errors are caused by external circumstances.
The user types in the wrong URL, as I mentioned.
They save to a full thumb drive.
Well, that's not the right way to handle that problem.
You don't want the program to terminate when that happens.
However, other errors are caused by you, the programmer.
Here, if you've made a mistake in your code,
you want the error to announce itself as soon as it's found
and stop at the point where the error occurs.
You don't want just the program to crash
and not tell you where the problem was.
You don't want it to fail silently,
because then you'll never find the bug.
To do this, we use a statement called an assert statement.
Now, this is inherited from the C language.
As you can see, the header file is called C assert.
All of the C inherited functions are C assert.
And in this, you just write assert counter is greater than 3.
If this was the precondition, the counter must be 3.
The advantage of assertions is it allows you to write self-checking code.
If you write a statement, you're certain, or you assume that it does one thing,
write an assertion for that.
This is called instrumenting your code.
This allows you to automatically detect and notify you when an error occurs.
Sometimes these are called sanity checks or smoke tests.
So you want to use assert only for things that cannot logically happen.
Don't use asserts for things where the user will input bad data.
Only for things that cannot logically happen.
So if I have a function called sumBetween,
I want to make sure that lower is not greater than upper.
And so I'm going to assert that lower is less than or equal to upper.
It's impossible for that not to pass.
Logically, that must be true for this function to have any sense at all.
And so I have on my slide here, it cannot happen,
but it really must happen.
Now assertions actually are something called a macro.
And a macro is a piece of code that this is going to expand
when I write assert lower less than or equal to upper.
It's going to say, if lower is greater than upper,
then terminate the program, print out the file number, and so forth.
So this is going to expand, we say the macro expands,
into an if statement.
And as you can imagine, a macro or an assert statement
takes time to do this check.
It takes time to do this automatic detection.
And so when we have found all of these logical errors in our code,
and we're ready to ship it out to our users,
what we call production code,
we would generally remove that code by defining the end debug symbol
before including cassert.
That simply replaces what the assert did with just nothing.
Now alternatively, and normally, we'll add a make debug
or make release flag to our make file,
and it will just pass in the -d end debug when we're compiling.
So we don't actually have to change the source code at all.
Okay, so that's it for this lecture.
We'll see you next time with lecture 14.